This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Christina
music.
Serious.
It's a who is this Mars
lover by your knees.
Your Yoni is New York.
It says,
um, Jean, what's going
on with you on the road?
Uh, November 24th in man, Diego,
California. I'll be doing that.
House of Blues. Get your tickets. Yeah,
that's not the Thanksgiving weekend.
What a better time to get out of
your God Damn House. It's fantastic.
Go to a show at that point, right?
December 8th, Gramercy theater.
I've added a late show, 10 30. Uh,
tickets are now on a regular sale.
We did a presale last week that went
gangbusters. Soap looks like judo.
Arc titties is coming out strong for
this main mommy and I appreciate that.
So get those tickets in advance.
And that's it for now.
But we're working on 2019.
I'm very excited.
There's some big cities coming up.
What about you Jean Jackets?
2019 is going to be absolutely
bananas for the two of us.
We're both doing a bunch of dates.
Yeah, I got many to announce soon,
but not yet. Um, there's
still some things. Let's see.
There was a few tickets left and
for the brayer weekend in August,
Friday, Friday tickets are
available for breast balls. Beach,
the West Palm Beach Improv.
That's in late August. Um,
let's see. September's
all sold out. October.
I have a few tickets left
at the second show in Boise.
The second show in Eugene,
Oregon is on sale now. A,
then there's ball Sacramento,
Fresno, Bakersfield,
and a pick. That's it. Let's
see. Oh, filler. Hurry up.
Delphia has a second show. Core. Lando,
Florida has a second show and a
Jacksonville, Fort Myers, Florida.
Jack me off a bill,
Jack, Phil and Augusta.
Those are all on sale. You know
better than that. Temecula,
uh,
to mass tickles nay at the
Pachanga resort and casino.
Those are, it sounds like it's a word for
pussy. It does. Those are all on sale.
[inaudible] dot com check them out.
Try it out and they enjoy, have fun.
All right.
Try it out.
You know how many emails we get and tweets
telling us that they can't even hear
the phrase, try it out now. That's
just a normal phrase. Ruined.
It's ruined it for people. Try it out.
It really makes me happy. Try it out.
Try it out. Try it out. Yeah.
Weird thing to say about that.
Like, come over and out. Piss
on me. But you also can't
hear about deals. Deal, man.
It's so weird. Try it out. I mean, I
know you've been thinking about it.
Why not try it out? Like that's
the shit inference, right?
We have a difference in France.
How do you say it? Yeah.
And it's what you're inferring
in France might be in France,
might be another one of those weird
foreign things because I was raised by
foreigners. Yeah. If I can
say anything you don't talk
in with good. Nope. Um, look,
let's get serious. A lot of people
want to talk silly stuff and um,
you know,
make light of unimportant things.
This is a little more sophisticated show.
Yeah.
And I'm kind of sick of the silliness.
I want to talk about real issues. Okay.
What'd you have on your mind? You know,
let's just have this introduction here.
This is from the BBC.
We're changing the format of the show
now is that whole show is going to get a
lot more serious political. We're going
to do politics. Absolutely. Every,
every week.
I went hard hitting geopolitical
international debates.
I want to talk about
comparative economics and I,
all right, sorry. I that's you know, you
do what you want to do. I'll do what I do.
Okay. Okay, here we go. And here you go.
Boom. Me Have Tom. It's
typically have sound off.
Sound has a frequency. What is the
frequency of a fart? Find out next.
No,
bring it in.
Go to your mom's house.
Let's talk about,
so your,
your thing is what frequency
are your farts? I've, you know,
it's funny because we watched that movie
about sounds. Oh God, I hated it. Yeah,
I know they didn't have one fart
in that look of all the questions.
Call a quiet place. Quiet place need to
be answered. How are they taking shits?
Yeah, they have diarrhea. How are they
farting? Those are the two biggest.
Are they burping John Krasinski,
Emily blunt, which I had.
They're married in real life, in real
life. Um, the movie was a big hit.
I mean, how are they
jerking off? They're not,
how are they watching porn
and masturbating? Nobody's,
none of that was addressed.
Yeah. None of it was addressed. How loud
he comes. Does he make a lot of noise?
Becomes, because if you don't
know the premise of the movie,
it did very well at the box.
It's that there's these
crazy aliens out there that,
um, kill anything basically
that makes a noise. Yeah.
So the is,
is an utter chaos.
And he and his family are living in,
out in a field somewhere, basically
in a farmhouse. And they, you know,
if you knock something over,
you immediately have to hide because these
aliens that kill everything are blind,
but they have super hearing.
So they hear every little noise.
Every fart. Yeah. Every
jacket. And if he's like, ah,
they would hear that,
you know,
that movie was so stressful.
Yeah.
How are they watching
powerpoints are suiting
Haley's, it killed everything.
She wants it like this.
It's a good movie. I,
I'm just stressed out
because of the content.
You are super stressed. I was
like, I tap out, tap out. I can't,
I can't watch children being,
I know
there's a lot and again, the big
issues of the film were not addressed.
Um, and that was upsetting. But we
stayed. So we stayed in a hotel.
We had a baby moon. Our very last one
before this baby jeans comes into town.
Right.
And has usual,
we were perusing the porn options
in the hotel room cause we will,
you know, the one was like daddy
loves my big tits. That's right.
I think that's [inaudible] favorite.
You can tell a lot about
the hotels clientele by what
kind of porn they offer in
the room.
A lot of transsexual porn,
lots of transsexual stuff.
But daddy loves my big test.
Really stood out.
Daddy loves my big debts.
And what really kind of upset me a with
these titles is that I'm leaving so much
money on the table right now because right
now I'm nine months pregnant and that
is such a lucrative porn category that
I'm not even taking a part of right now.
I don't even,
where's my cut?
It's out there. It's out there.
If you're ready to make a move.
It seems like the natural
money on the table,
desire for a pregnant woman to have.
When you're around men and women a lot,
nine months to you,
you realize you're like, why aren't
you doing porn? Right. It seems like,
would they all work? Yeah. It's an
ideal time. Your body looks great,
you feel great.
You're at the top of your game.
You are leaving $100 just hundreds
sitting out there everywhere. Yeah.
How much do you think a woman
gets for that genre? I don't know.
I don't know because I know that
without being really keyed into it,
that that whole business model has
taken such a hit because of free,
you know, tube sites. Yeah, so it used
to be when people made a lot of money,
you know,
at first
of all, there was born, used
to be in cinema is that it was,
you had to go by cinema, cinema, cinema.
Then you had to go buy video tapes
or DVDs. Imagine eating popcorn,
watching, going to it as the
most vile, disgusting thing ever.
The whole thing is don't you want
to be alone when you watch porn?
How do you sit through like an hour and
change of a movie and not jerk off with
each other? Even if you
go like, I'm not going to.
It's like then aren't you just always
distracted by other guys drinking at it
had to have just been a jerk fest and
these theaters and the, I'm sorry,
the cinema as you referring
to the cinema. Yeah, but then,
then they got paid money because
they sold a lot of videotapes.
Put you on the cover and you
know you were, you were selling,
you were selling copies and then
DVDs. But now with, with free,
I think it's really driven the money down.
So,
but I think you're at least making a
few hundred bucks for your pregnant porn
scene and the good news. But
it's not, it's a niche thing.
It's not like, you know,
but that's why it's even more in
demand. I don't know, is it? I Dunno,
but the good news is I
can't get pregnant again.
So I feel like I should be working a
lot right now. This is an ideal time.
Would you do like the airtight,
the two and you three and you tied
again at one in every hole. I mean,
I'm already pregnant. So
what's to lose? You're,
the cool thing is you have something
to show that kid too, you know? I mean,
right now you can show your kid that you
just stand up pregnant. That's exciting.
Not really. Not compared to three decks
in you and being like you're in there,
you're in the scene. Yeah. It's a
really cool thing to share with a child.
It is.
And also that would be a good clip.
And also who is that? That's
an Natasha. Oh my gosh.
Can we talk about these two by the way?
First of all,
let's let go or drop it all
over the tunnels. Seriously.
You really do have to be hard up.
Did you? Nine month pregnancy porn,
like you gotta be in Dire Straits. Well,
or just really committed to the game.
Really committed. I think that
there's a level of commitment there.
I know it kind of reminds me of
the crossfit games, right? Those,
those people work out a lot.
You know,
I follow fit moms of Instagram and there's
all these lunatic women who are nine
months pregnant doing dead lifts. Is
that what that's called? Where the um,
over their bellies and shit
and jumping up on boxes.
Power cleans and snatches. Yeah.
It's my favorite. It's so crazy.
One of my greatest motivators.
I know it sounds super sexist,
but I look at it and I'm like, Holy Shit,
I do, I do think of it as motivation.
I know someone will take it the wrong
way because this is the era of taking
everything social justice
warrior well deal with it.
We got to tweet about this.
Some women that are like
workout warriors that are
like 125 pounds that are stronger than me.
Sure.
So I look at it and I'm like,
this chick is out
squatting me out cleaning.
Like it's out. I look at it and
I'm like, Holy Shit. I mean,
it sounds like I'm saying, you
know, this is certainly possible,
but I'm really just amazed by
it, you know? I think that,
I think I feel your amazement too.
Yeah.
And I see like a tiny check and
you're like, how is she so pi?
I saw a Instagram thing,
I should look it up who it is.
But this woman was, I mean like
it looks like she's about five,
325 pounds. I mean, totally yoked,
but throwing around real weight,
like cleaning real weight.
And I was like, oh my God, I need to get
into the gym more. It's amazing, isn't it?
She's a fucking half my size. It's
amazing. And people are capable of, yeah.
I mean obviously I'll never work out
to the degree that she works out of her
whole life is working out,
but it still was amazingly motivating.
Yeah, of course. Uh, my
favorite are the Instagram,
the fit moms of Instagram and
there'll be like four days postpartum,
totally flat stomach six pack. You're
like, are you fucking out of your mind?
Like it's okay. It's just relax here.
Give yourself a minute. That's a lot.
You don't need to go back
to the gym right away.
24 hours after you had the
babies be fat for a minute. Look.
So we were talking about those.
Finish this a frequency thing. Okay,
so, so that, that whole movie,
I don't want to give it away,
but they're just trying to find,
you know what can defeat
these super sonic aliens.
And it got us thinking about sounds
and frequencies because there that's,
that's what they're dealing with.
I mean just try to learn a little bit.
Try to open your mind and learn a little
bit here. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Human
farts come in. All ranges of
sounds. There are popcorn farts,
which sounded like their name
typically have the same note.
There are also longer farts ones that
slide up from one note to the other.
Typically doing the musical scale.
That's right. That's really interesting.
So if you want it to find
the frequency of a Fart,
how would you go about doing that?
First off,
you would need to find out
which note you're farting.
It might be a good idea
to record the park.
Then using a piano or if
you're a trained singer,
you could use your voice to find the
note or notes. Once you find the note,
you can then consult this chart to
find the corresponding frequency.
How much,
oh,
she did not like farts at all.
What is the average farmer?
Sequency science has not yet provided
the answer to the average fart frequency
as of 2015 and while this is a rather
unscientifically provided hypothesis,
the average fire frequency likely ranges
in between note c two and c six or
130.81 and 1040 6.5 hertz.
Huh? Well, hold on a second. I
mean this is just fascinating.
I don't even know what that means,
but would it be important for snow,
the frequency of a fart? Yeah. Well,
there's probably no real reason to know
this information other than to entertain
yourself or your friends or is that still,
this video actually gives you
a lesson in sound engineering.
This is similar to the
technique recording. Engineers
use it, unwanted sound,
so they can cancel them out in the mix
by finding the frequency of a tone,
or in this case,
a fart one can remove the sound or boost
it by finding that frequency in an ICU
and manipulating it from there.
Okay. He lost, I was like,
why are we removing frequencies of words?
Okay.
That sounds like a d minor.
Is that the,
I don't know anything about chicken on
frequencies and sounds, any of that.
But I just feel like king after ever
it would blow away this engine. Yeah.
This is bullshit.
Bring in some real farts.
Bringing some of those as far
as for like children's, my,
our toddler farts like that. Yeah. But
back to what you were saying. So we,
we had Moshe and Natasha n
they have a special on Netflix,
uh,
the honeymoon tour and
they were delightful and we
learned so much about them,
but I think the real carry away and the
thing that's been kind of sticking to
you and me is the fact that
they don't fart in front of me.
Oh
yeah. I mean, a great drop.
Yeah. Um, yeah, I know they, uh,
they don't, here's, wow.
Six years of med carts.
Listen,
I can't even wrap my brain around
something like that. It's crazy.
It's really wild. I mean, I dunno.
Here's the thing is like now
you can't, I mean, I think it's,
I think in a way the woman leads,
right?
Because what would make
this clear to a man? No.
If you make it clear that it's not excel,
like really not acceptable,
where she's made it clear, it's
not going to happen. Right. Um,
then you're only doing that because
you want to really upset that person.
I feel like I started that lead and our
relationship and then it was completely
disregarded. It was this regard. Right.
But it was also met with a
embracement and joy. I don't know.
I don't know about that.
I just know that I had wishes I had
things established and those wishes we're
just done away with.
I waited months
three, four, three, four,
and he put my hand in your lap.
We were watching TV together.
You're sitting in your boxers as usual.
Yeah.
And you farted on my hand
and just started laughing.
Well, I thought that was,
that was bold. That's bold.
And it was a, it's like, why I just
sneak one out. Why not just go for it?
Yeah.
Well I
think, oh, are you break up immediately?
I think even if you had a kid
together should divorce you. Really?
I don't think she's done that move.
She's not.
What if he did that move now that
that'd be grounds for termination.
I don't think that would be cool for her.
Yeah,
because they're not even doing
the lean over and fart well. Well,
and what's really interesting about
their interview is that they don't even
announce when they have to take
dumps in front of each other,
which I find so hard. I mean, how do you
live with somebody every day, day to day,
and you, you just disappear for five.
Fascinated though. Because yeah,
it also has insight into understand
how other, I mean that's first of all,
it's not,
we're not talking about three months in.
This is six years and a baby,
which generally breaks down
a lot of those barriers.
If you've seen a woman give birth,
you generally then you kind of admire it.
Right. But they stay that committed
to keeping it. I honestly,
yeah. I mean look, I'm not
trying to pass judgment on them.
I'm just trying to understand how you can
go without farting and she didn't want
to talk about shitting for six
years. Well that's fine. It's jump.
Well that makes you 40 even more.
It's a good point. A lot of veggies.
I feel like he eats pretty
healthy, right? Yeah.
I feel like he's holding a lot
of farts. I mean, look, my,
my ex, step mom and dad,
my stepmom had this policy,
this no Farnese she ever
fart in front of you? Never.
Not in the 17 years I knew her.
Now my dad on the other hand would
disregard it from time to time when I was
around at least.
And then we would have a good laugh at
the fort and she would get very upset and
she would leave and get
really, really, really mad.
So I think they had that no fart policy.
Right.
What about the sneak outs in the middle
of the night? Oh, those don't count those,
those, those anybody would forgive.
That's a completely unreasonable,
but I'm talking about you're
awake. You got to Fart. I mean,
how many a day are we?
Oh my gosh.
And then what if you ate Korean barbecue
and you've had Kimchi and the farts are
just a lot that day. So what do
you, you're holding it in all day.
It's gotta be very definitely. My favorite
parts are the ones that wake you up
parts all the time.
Nice.
I was just asleep bar.
Can you do it all the time?
You do it constantly makes me, it
makes me laugh a lot. I don't know.
I mean again, I'm not judging them.
That's totally their decision.
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
how it would be even possible for us.
I'm saying [inaudible] I'm really just
thinking about us. It can't happen.
By the way. Speaking of
your, uh, your porn quest,
your pregnancy porn,
the mommies are flooding
some comments in porn hub.
There's a comment section there.
This is like if you keep your
jeans high and tight, 250 thumbs
up here. Oh Wow. Um, then someone
wrote, try it out in 92 thumbs up.
So it's like we have a
fan base here on pornhub.
Pornhub he should have taken
about 10 to 12 Benadryl.
That stuff makes you horny or than
you've ever been in your entire yeah.
Buy it out. Piss on me. Beat me. Try it
out. Hey, Hitler's, I mean, these are all,
what clip is this form? It doesn't
mention here. I Dunno. Hmm.
It's black guys who like to fuck and
fuck. Good. It's pretty good. Yeah. Oh,
it's one, it looks like it says it's one
of the, uh, a ball hog videos. Oh yeah.
That would make sense.
So said I had to check out the porn hub,
a ball hog videos,
horrific. Who wants to see someone
slur pound balls for 80% of the video.
Anyways, she just wanted to let you
know that Mommy's took over the comment.
So it is, it is on the, um, the ball hog.
Hi, I'm Payton Lafferty and
Bajan Lafferty. Yeah. Before,
I forget, uh, movies.
We were watching a trailer for that movie.
Mamma Mia came on for something like
say, I know and I, it's so funny.
It's like an all star cast
too. It's fit. I'm sure. Yeah.
Meryl Streep share and all
these, you know. Um, but I,
I can't think of something I'd want to
watch less. Pretty fucking terrible.
I mean,
and then I got to thinking,
what are the other horrible movies I
can make you watch? So would you rather,
would you rather sit
through Mama Mia and I mean,
you got to go to theater and really
sit down and watch every stupid thing.
I enjoy all the Abba songs or Chicago.
He had a comment Danna it's all
like the crime that you know,
is Queen Latifah's in there.
It's really hard for me to say.
It's really hard for me. When we saw a
little bit of Chicago, we saw six seconds.
It was on TV. It is unbearable.
That's right. It was through the TV.
Fuck it out the window. But
I mean, they seem terrible.
They're both terrible. I
hate musicals, so I see why.
And it musical movies or even worse.
I lasted literally the first,
not even to the completion of the first
scene of La la land because they started,
oh, I forward it through all the songs in
that. I just like Ryan Gosling hate it.
I walked out of the movie about PT Barnum.
I didn't know that fucking was
a musical. It's a musical. Yeah.
I went to the theater to go see it and
then halfway through the first song I was
like, I don't know if I can do this. I my
the third song, I was like, I'm, I'm out.
Down. Yeah. Got Go. I don't like it. I
was pregnant. I walked home cold. Really?
Like I can't fucking,
I can't you walk. Yeah.
It was an out Puto was I proud?
Yeah. No, no. I wasn't pregnant then.
Hmm. And Short Lake shortlink
shitty happening mean.
How do I pick one of these awful
fucking thing? I don't know.
Here's my mamma mia has a chick flick,
so chicargo. Yeah, but Mama Mia is Arba.
Do you like Aba?
I can tolerate it. I guess.
I think I probably like
Aba more.
Then the straight up Chicago
musical songs for that,
for that movie.
Yeah.
Those are terrible because those are like
traditional songs for a musical story
I could tolerate. Ah, but more, you
know what I don't like about Chicago?
I will say what I did watch it for
like the Queen Latifa St Louis.
She's like the boss, the prison
guard who like runs stuff. Yeah.
It's sort of the repetition
of the chorus or whatever.
I'm the boss lady.
They call me the boss and I'm the boss
and our boss you around and you're like,
I fucking heard you say that. Like
I get it. You're the boss. People.
Some people love this shit.
The repetition. Well, you
know, here's the thing. Yeah.
I, I, the older I get,
the more I understand that people like
all kinds of different things. Yeah.
And you know,
it enrages you sometimes. Yeah. Um,
what's funny to me is that they don't,
the people that love that get
mad at you for not loving it.
That's the funny part to sure.
Because I remember when we talked about
slam poetry and we made fun of that and
then people would write in like, I
love him. Like go love it. Why are you,
why does it affect you? What I like,
I'm just telling you what I like.
I know they get so personally offended.
Yeah.
It's like these are just opinions
of here's one or two people.
I like Alba's music.
I actually you could tolerate that.
I grew up listening to it because
both my parents are euro, you know?
They liked that stuff, so
I like Fernando. I like,
I like a lot of the Aba song then you
other than this, an easy choice for you,
but it's an annoying fucking movie. It's
annoying. Yeah. It is a good cast though.
And I don't want to
hear them sing my songs.
I want to hear Aba singing Meryl
Streep, Pierce Brosnan, Colin firth.
It's a good, it's a good, yeah,
but it's so lame how they incorporate
the music into it, you know? Yeah.
So this must have been it. Was this a
huge hit when it came out originally?
The original one? Yeah, I think
it Mama Mia has been out for,
I was a musical for a long time and
then they did these movies of it and now
there's a sequel to the first
Mama Mia. Yeah, she's pregnant.
So those were my mom got her pussy
blasted out. Right. Yeah. Uh,
but yeah,
it's a lot of us euro trash.
There's Love Mama Mia and I'm pretty
sure my stepmom went to go see it.
Yeah. You think so? Yeah. Yeah.
There was something. He liked that. So
Fernando,
I like Fernando and there's no regrets.
It's kind of Nice. Right. Okay.
Yeah. That's fair. My belly. Oh,
this check vote. You've
got an email. Yeah. Um,
yeah.
It's amazing. Just listening to episode
four or 53 about female super burps.
Yup.
Yup. My girlfriend of three years always
burps this way. She doesn't even try.
Just how it comes out,
to be honest.
This is one of the things that sealed
the deal on that relationship early on.
That's a beautiful eastern European
redhead. Burping loud, a super sexy.
I've always had super far. It's, I love
spicy foods and have huge farts every day.
We had the perfect balance in our
relationship. She's 39 weeks pregnant now.
Oh my God.
Your grants.
The end of our second trimester,
she's had super far. It's as well now.
She is totally dominating me in the gas
gauge and I'm feeling a little jealous.
She even had a supersonic double
pipe classic a few weeks ago. Wow.
Congratulations on that.
More so than the baby.
What do you suggest I do about
this blatant emasculation Mommy's.
I love the show. Love you both
keep those jeans high and tight.
Piss on me and beat me home here now.
David.
I, I'm here now. Yeah. What
do you mean emasculation I
think you need to celebrate.
No. Why? Why does it have to? Well cause
he's feeling makes what you're doing. Oh,
he's feeling a little left out. She's
trumping hardcore in this stuff. Yeah,
but pregnancy is kind of an unfair
advantage and the double, that's not true.
I would say this,
David,
you better celebrate for about another
week because it's about to be over.
So just know that it's
temporary. You know, it's almost
like she has a cheat code.
She does have a Chico. Yeah. And
once that baby jeans comes out,
the baby's going to have more farts and
both of you so time to get over it. Yeah.
It's, um, get over
yourself. She's, it's, it's,
it's time to, uh, let
her know that, you know,
she can enjoy this while it lasts because
it's not going to last much like she's
39 weeks pregnant. She's right there,
man. She's right at their door.
That's so funny. Uh, this female were
far too. We'll be back and you'll,
you'll don't you worry. Yeah. Um,
I love the idea that women are strong in
the burb game. Yeah. It's pretty cool.
It's good.
Could start a whole gender war now
between who's better at burping the men or
the women? Yeah. At the BURP challenge.
It's pretty quiet. Pretty crazy. I mean,
sometimes I feel like mine are better
than yours and sometimes years are better
than mine. You feel like sometimes.
Yeah. I, the fort game is really yours.
Like I'm going to give it to you. I
feel really dominate, but the verb game,
here's why your farts are
consistent. Yeah. Over time. I'm,
I'm more regular. Yeah. But
sometimes my burp game is strong.
Sometimes yours is,
if that's true,
it's kind of go here and there. Um,
another reminder before I forget,
they try to remind people
that new episodes are going
on twitch before youtube.
So, uh, we will be experimenting a little
further down the road with live ones.
But for right now,
Youtube uploads at 11:00 PM Pacific,
Tuesday evenings twitch,
we'll do 9:00 PM Pacific and it's
twitch.tv/your mom's house podcast.
So there is that reminder.
Yeah, I mean, I dunno what,
well, I just feel like, I feel like
far it's kind of go back and forth too.
Well, it all fluctuates. It's all
cycles and seasons, you know? Yeah. Uh,
so we were driving yesterday home and I
saw somebody walking their dog shirtless
as usual, which I find horrifically
disgusting. I don't know.
I don't know why guys think it's okay
to go shirtless if I can't go shirtless.
It's kind of unfair.
Anyways,
I had one of those things,
Tommy,
where I've been saying something one way
for 42 years and then you pointed out
to me like smart and final. I
remember when I was like, dude,
I don't even know what's
in smart and final.
I thought it was like office supplies.
Like yeah you're smart but all sales are
final. I had no idea that smart finals,
like a grocery type of store.
Well Anyway, yesterday I go,
that guy's wearing a sun visor. How
fucking lame is that? Like a sun visors,
the fucking most useless thing cause
you're top of your head is burning and you
go,
it's not as nice or you dork.
It's just called a visor and my fucking
head exploded because I'm like my whole
life, my parents have called
it a sun visor and chewing gum.
I've heard chewing gum my whole life.
So I thought everybody calls it chewing
gum or a sun visor. I mean it might be
what I told you was that it might
technically have started as started out as
people saying a sun visor,
like in the 70s maybe like when if first
came whenever they first designed them,
but my whole life,
whenever someone is referring to that hat,
no one says son,
it's just like a Pfizer.
Are you sure?
100% because both my foreign parents call.
Like I said,
I thought it made sense.
A sports visor also call these sun
visor or visor cap is a type of crown,
let's hat blah blah blah.
It's a visor, Pfizer,
but, but you're more American than I am.
Right, and I would take your word over.
Well,
it,
like I said, I think technically
it might be called a sun visor.
Maybe makes sense that
that was the original name.
But if you're talking to people here,
you would just say advisor,
like you know
you wouldn't, you wouldn't say hand me
that son. You'd say, Oh really? Yeah.
You wouldn't say, give me a
piece of chewing gum. I've
been saying that for four.
Know that you're, you're, you're standing
out as not being from here. Yeah.
I mean, everybody would know what you
meant. My, everybody knows what you mean.
But they also are like, this person just
learned English. Like, yeah, it's advisor.
I've been saying chewing gum and sun visor
my whole life until, until yesterday.
So I'm wiser for me and I've never
sell, but that, that's interesting.
I just never heard,
I guess I've never been around
people who use that word enough.
My mother called it a sun visor,
so I called it a sun visor.
This looks like that.
The thing for your windshield,
they're coming that have sun shade.
Uh Huh.
But remember those were popular in
the 80s everyone has a seat.
Not even that mission that's
come up here for Sun visor.
It's interesting. Yeah. That was
funny. He did go, hey, a sun visor.
Look at that. Look at that lady walked
by. It's like, give me an advisor.
They're so lame. Sun visors though, just
makes the top of your head hot. So dumb.
Why would you bring your wine? I
Dunno. Like, yeah, if it's hot,
it implies that the sun's
out and cook in your head.
So why would you leave that
part of your head uncovered?
And then why don't I just
wear a cap, right. Um,
should we pause for a moment? Cause our,
our guests should be here any moment.
Press pause.
Can we do that?
It's like a quick pause and
we'll be right back. All right,
we're back.
We took a quick break and our guests is
joining us now he says here you've done
some acting. It says there, I've done
some acting. Yes, that was proofreading.
Yes, I have done that. I have done acting.
When I first got into stand up, um,
that's all I wanted to
do with stand up comedy.
I was hanging up the Improv and
stuff and, and um, one day mark Leno,
who was bud Freeman, so partner business
partner, uh, sat down next to me, he goes,
hey, you ever think about acting? And
I said, not really. I just kind of,
you know what I'm want to do. Stand
up. That's all I want to do. Yeah.
You don't think about acting.
Cause sometimes there'll be a casting
agent will come in and see you in the back
room and want you to come in and do a
cold reading for their pilot or whatever,
you know, it could be a good thing.
So I'm also, he taught acting,
so that was his good. But I did take up
acting and I did a lot of workshops and,
um, and I'm glad I did. Yeah,
I mean you've made a quite,
I should probably say your name. It's a,
it's Kevin Nealon. Everybody who is a,
who's listening to us.
Thank you first of all for coming over.
I really appreciate it. It was easy. I
live upstairs. I didn't know, you know,
you were going to ever come
down. That's the thing. I mean,
I heard a lot of noise down here and I
thought there must be people that live
down there. Look, it's so real that
you're sitting in front of me. Um,
because first of all, first of all,
what the fuck are you taking? Is it,
is this how you don't look older? This
juice? What? What's going on? We know.
I just started drinking orange juice.
Yeah.
Never used to drink that much of it
because it had a lot of sugar in it.
And I'm trying to cut down
on my sugar intake. But,
and also I used to have oatmeal every
morning and that changed about two weeks
ago. Right now I switched over
to eggs. Why the sudden change?
I think I just got tired of uh,
oatmeal,
the oatmeal over and over flavor
it or just plain. Oh well I'm,
I'm the king of oatmeal.
I'll go back to it too.
And I'm just taking a little
hiatus, a little lunch. We've been,
we've been on eggs for a while. I hate
him and I ate them. I forced myself to.
What do you need to, well, I
mean, okay, I even asked you this.
I think when I saw you laugh factory it,
is this just genetic.
This is why you look like you, you did in
1994. Well, I am rotting on the inside.
You'll ask the problems, see that makes
you happy. Cause it really upsets me that,
um, that you, you maintain
so well. How old are you?
I am 20 Kevin Guess how
old do you want to guess? Um, I
have, you're like one of those,
you look at Golfer, I can't tell how old
you are. I mean your eyes look young.
The rest of you, it looks
really, really decrepit.
I we're going to go ahead and say
that's pretty good.
Guess I'm 39
I used to call him the
Albert pools of comedy. Yeah.
Cause you know a lot
of the baseball player,
especially with Dominican guys would
lie about their age when the recruiters
went down.
So they'd be the only like 17 in the
scouts would show up and they'd be like,
I'm 14 and then they would get signed and
pool halls was the guy who [inaudible]
17 was too old. Yeah, yeah. Well, yeah,
they would because they'd be playing in
these like little league teams and then
then the guy would finally get in the
majors and really some of them really
start to show their age and they'd
be like, your 23. The guy's like, no,
I'm actually 31 but you know, they just,
they did whatever it took to get in.
Well, I think genetically I was kind of
lucky because when I was on high school I
looked like I was 12 when I graduated.
If you look at my high school yearbook
picture, I really, I had no body here.
I was so embarrassed because I was so
far behind everybody. And um, and I have,
I was five, eight when I graduated
high school. I'm six, four,
nine what you were finding when you
graduated high school and I had a lot of
baby fat on me and stuff and um,
and then I just shot up after a
high school, you know, I got to,
I went to college and I
got a job lifeguarding and
they was sitting out in the
sun where I just started
growing. Yeah. But, um,
you actually graduated high school as
what would be considered a short guy if
five. Eight is the average
size? Maybe a little lower.
I'm not sure what a c has a tall person.
You don't really think about height.
You just,
the only time I think about highest when
I see a really tall guy and I think,
man, that guy's tall. Oh,
am I that tall? I hope not.
And I'll stand next to
him without him knowing.
I really thank God I'm not that tall.
I think I'm like just a
hair below freakishly tall.
And that's what I get a lot from people
when they first see me, they say,
I didn't realize you were
this tall. I said, I know.
I just realized that the other day.
It's so genuinely upsetting too.
It's another thing about it,
you know? Yeah. It's upsetting
how tall you are. Yeah.
Because yeah, it's like when
you expect to have like a, uh,
a nice big corn on the cob and all
they have is like a corn dog. Oh man,
you weren't, you didn't have that
picture in your head. And I see.
Trying to think if I've ever imagined how
tall you were, because I remember, um,
you know,
my first exposure to you was weekend
update and I don't think you have when you
were watching that. Yeah,
of course you don't have,
yeah. You had your TV's not
that big either. You know,
I tell people they need to get a bigger
TV that way they'll see how tall I am
and how tall you are. I'm not like five
inches tall. Where did you grow up?
I grew up in Connecticut. Bridgeport,
Connecticut. Not Proud of it,
but I heard they just got
a new comedy called bear.
I be first comedy club in Bridgeport.
Bridgeport? Yeah. Where's bridges factory?
It's um, it's about an hour and 15
minutes north of New York City. Oh,
it's really long island sound.
Yeah.
So would you go in there a
lot because there's no, I was,
I was really afraid of New York City,
uh, growing up in Connecticut because,
because it was a big city and there was
all these one way streets and the New
Yorkers were tough, you know, and so I,
and it was hard to drive in there too,
cause you had to get on the merit
parkway and then get over to all of these
other freeways and stuff and
the traffic was going fast.
And so I didn't go into that much that
really the first time I went in there on
school trips to the museum. But
the first time I, I, I, you know,
looked at a comedy club. I drove in
there and I went to see the catch,
a rising star and the comic strip and,
um,
um, the Improv. And it was just,
I was like a farm boy going into a city,
you know,
it was just lights and cars
everywhere and you know, but, um,
but, but getting back to the
genetic thing, I think that, um,
I really am,
my body has taken a toll because I played
football and rugby and soccer growing
up, so I have like hip like three
years ago. Did you really? Yeah,
my right side and, um, my
shoulders are like really sore now.
I think there's probably
arthritis in there and, uh,
and then when I pee I get this pain
in my back. It's like a kidney stone.
Every p no, only kind of like, after
I worked out I did a hike, you know?
Um, yeah, that checked out or you
guys doctors, I can hear, okay,
I can do it. No, I did have
it checked out. Well again,
I'm at that age now where they don't
find anything wrong. It's just a muscle,
just like you're dying slowly, but
you're decomposing. Yeah, yeah.
No, but I have had kidney stones
before and that's not fun. Really bad.
Does the Jews help the
juice helps? Yeah, no,
I'm a water helps a lot of water.
Thankfully I won't have them.
I drink a lot of water drinks,
Brown coffee all day long.
Does that help with kidney stones? Coffee
actually they say is good for you now,
isn't it? Yeah, it's mostly water.
That's the thing. Yeah, it makes you pee.
I thought it was dehydrating. You don't
know what that word means. So Pete,
now you know what? PBNS pains,
but I did get a, here's a,
here's a word you need to familiarize
yourself with and you want to avoid this.
It's called a cystoscopy.
Cystoscopy.
It's what you get after you've had a
kidney stone. It's through the Cody.
Your knowledge as urologists. Yeah.
And you don't really know what it is.
They say it's not pleasant,
but you'll be okay. So yeah,
you sit back and they
take a, uh, you know,
a tube and they numb your penis and um,
they didn't have the
numbing solution was there.
So I had to sit on it for like a
half hour to make it go to sleep.
Oh my goodness. And then they shoved
that thing up there into your bladder.
Oh
yeah,
they got a little ritual,
Dick. Yeah, yeah. That's,
but so anyway, I did that one time
and they found nothing up there.
How painful was that?
Yeah. You know what it,
it was kind of like, um,
even though they numbed it,
it was still kind of like, uh, I just
stopped short of saying take it out,
take it out. Yeah. You know, I had a
catheter in one time in the hospital,
I was in the hospital and
the nurse tripped. Oh.
And it pulled out like,
how, and I was like, ah.
She was like, ah, I'm sorry. It
wasn't supposed to happen. I was like,
don't say anything. Don't tell anybody
breathing. So yeah, don't get me fired.
Gosh, you guys talking about all these
painful things. I hope I don't have to.
Yeah. Here's the funny thing.
Here's a fun one. When I was 23,
I had a bump on my neck. Yeah. And uh,
I went to some doctor back then
in Bridgeport, Connecticut.
And this is when you could
smoke in the doctor's office.
And he was smoking a big cigar and he
reaches across his desk and he feels it
with his two fingers. And he goes, okay,
what you have here is a, a a tumor.
And when he said tumor that
mixed with a cigar smoke,
I started to get narrow vision.
Yeah.
And I was starting to feel faint and he
looked and he was talking about it and
he, and he saw it how I
looked because you all right,
you want me to open a window? I said,
yet, please open up one window. So
I said the, the, the,
the tumor thing kind of like
pushed a button on me right there.
I was 23 of course. And he
goes, well, I call it a tumor,
but it's just fatty tissue, fatty
tissue, but we'll take it out, you know,
just to do a biopsy on. I'm sure it's
nothing. So I went to, in the hospital,
I just got out of college.
You know what, I'm ready for
my whole life. Yeah. And, um,
and they put me in a room with another
guy who would just come out of surgery
and they wheel him in and he starts waking
up and, you know, he's awake and he's,
uh, you know, kind of recovering.
And like an hour later,
I'm going in the next morning for surgery,
the nurse comes in and says to him,
have you, uh, have you peed yet? He
goes, no, no, I haven't. He goes, okay,
well,
you're going to have to pee soon,
otherwise we're going to have to
catheterize you. Yeah. He goes, he says,
w w what's catheterize me? Oh boy as
well. And she told them, hey. He said,
ah, no, that's not going to happen.
There's going to be a battle in here.
I want Ginger Ale. Give me a lot of
ginger rail right now. Ginger Ale,
tres or Ginger Ale. And I'm thinking, oh
Geez. Oh my God. And then I told them,
I said, hey, would you do me a favor
when I come out of surgery tomorrow?
Which you please make sure
I drink a lot of territory.
That's what they do do after childbirth.
What am I at first son?
The minute that epidural wears off,
they get around you and they're like,
you have to pee and if you don't, we're
going to put the catheter back in. Oh boy.
You Push that pee out. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
It's hard as you hit that epidurals.
The greatest though, isn't it? It's
the best. Oh, my do drags. I love it.
My wife had one at one centimeter. Yeah.
That's what you want to barely at all.
That's what I'm going to do.
People are usually one centimeter,
one centimeter right now.
Yeah. That's what I said.
Every time I see my doctor, I go,
when do I get the drugs? And he goes,
whenever you want. You know, I
think the epidural would be, uh,
an epidemic like opioids.
If it wasn't so difficult to put in that
needle right now know that would be,
but you're so grateful for it.
I don't even,
I want to feel where you're
feeling that you want. Yeah.
The childbirth or the epidural.
The epidural. It's pretty Rad.
You just take a nap and stuff and they
wake you up and they kind of got to know
what you're doing to get an epidural.
Like when you, if you do a home pregnancy,
don't let your husband give you
the Epicor. Yeah, I've heard,
I've heard
married 12 years.
Oh Wow. And we had a couple in here, uh,
last episode and they've been together
for six years and they last it off
and we were so surprised to find that
they don't fart in front of each other.
My wife doesn't Fart in front of me.
At least
my son and I, we are creative
artists. Yeah. I love it. We,
um, we make it a entertainment
thing. It's like shooting the gun.
Oh yeah. Tickling something, you know,
pulling the finger kind of thing.
That's the initial,
but we've taken it to new heights,
you know, lift the leg up or you don't,
and whenever I do it, when he's with me,
yeah. He outside, like he'll get
really embarrassed. Sure. Look around,
make sure nobody's look, I said,
buddy, buddy, I'm a pro man.
I'm doing this for years. No one's
around. I love, I love the movement.
I like to do like fun
in bed. I'll do like,
I'll kick it off. But yeah, my wife has
never fired one time she let us weaker.
But I'm imagining you don't
like sit on her and but,
but I mean like if you have to,
if you have to fart in your
weft around like do you, do
you leave the room? No, no,
no. But she's from the south so she's
very proper. Where's she from? Nashville.
You know, she's a southern Belle so I
try not to kind of do it around her.
Do you get up and leave the room or what
I do is I cut back on the sugar cause
that's what does it. You like
sugar, don't you? Of course.
And I've tried to eliminate
it. You can't, it's, it's a,
I went without it for a long
time. How long? As long,
cause I did it for six months.
Ones. Oh, I did a year.
But you know what happens?
You a congratulations
first of all. Yeah. You Go,
oh maybe I'll just have a little
piece of that scone of course.
And that's a trigger and then it
opens up the gate. It's like a,
it's like cocaine. Oh it goes
crazy. Someone was telling
me that if you had, um,
if sugar was just discovered now,
they would never approve it
cause it would be too addictive.
I totally believe that. And the sugar
lobby is massive. It's so powerful.
It's in everything. It's in
everything. And it is like,
it is horrific for your system.
It does nothing but dancer feeds on
it. You know, it's horrible. It's,
you see how much people consume it. It's
really crazy. Here's a great thing to do.
Go to the movie theater, like going
to crowded, you know, screen. Yeah.
And um,
about 10 minutes into the film,
just walk up in front by the
screen and look at the audience.
They are shoving so much food,
junk into their mouths and I'm,
I'm one of those people, you
know, and I just, you know,
and I say the first 10 minutes,
cause everybody plows through their stuff.
I usually finish my popcorn
before the trailers are over.
Yeah. Most people, yeah.
Like if you get it beforehand at the
temptation to just go through it because
the $20 popcorn is so good.
It's so good.
Penny counter. Every time I take a kernel
there was 5 cents, 25 cents right there.
So you're just running,
you're running that tap the whole time.
Speaking of cinema, do
you remember, did you,
I don't know how long you been in La for,
but I remember in like the eighties,
the late seventies,
there was like the pussycat theater,
which they would show
pornography in movie theaters.
Did you ever go to one?
Like what we're trying to like,
like basically we were saying how the
money has been driven down for the
performers and actors,
cause he used to be in cinema and then
people would buy videotape to DVDs and
now it's like free on
youtube. It's not, you know,
really well people are stealing
it and just playing it.
So did you ever go to cinema to a movie
theater? Was that a common thing to do?
To See Porno? Yeah. No, but I remember
peewee Herman that time. That'll be, yeah.
You know, um, no,
but I've worked in theaters before and
I'm sure you have too, where they say,
you know,
this what used to be a Vaudeville thing,
and the last thing was a porno
theater. Yeah, that's true
model. Yeah, that's true.
Um, but, um, but I will tell you,
I used to be a bartender at the
Improv when I first moved out.
It's so crazy to me too
that you're actually one of
those because there's always
these stories about,
it was just the job I got as I was
trying to become a standup, you know,
it wasn't like I was a bartender and
then they said all this frequenting the
Improv when you were, let me tell you
and then remind me about this story.
Let's got theater. Um, I was, I,
first night I walked in and I knew
the Improv was the place in La.
So I came out here and I got a job. Uh,
I befriended the bartender and he says,
Hey, we need a bartender for
like Sunday, Monday nights.
I can get you a job if you want. And I'd
never bartended before. So I kind of, uh,
you know,
boned up on that and I got the Boston
bartender's guide and I kept it behind the
bar and I refer to it a lot,
you know,
but I'm the first night I went in there
to sit at the bar or even to my right,
I'm looking in the mirror and it's this
weird looking guy and I'm looking at him
and it's Marty Feldman
and then there's a guy sitting next to me,
we start talking and he tells me
he's the original Ronald McDonald.
Later I find out he wasn't,
it was Bob's and Buddha Kaufman's
a kind of right hand man, you know,
and he was just messing with me.
But I would see everybody
come in there as I bartended.
I would see all these comics I used
to watch on the MERV Griffin show.
I'm like Douglas and the tonight's
show and all these, you know,
like Dadi Archibald and
George Miller and you know,
Jay Leno and Letterman and everybody,
Steve Martin call one night said,
looking for Bud Freeman.
He wasn't in,
you want to know if you'd come
down to a spot. I said, yes, yes,
you're on the phone. Yeah. And
then I see, you know, like,
and then the back room was
packed with comics that were,
had such a charge to them. Like, you
know, like Andy Kaufman would come in,
Robin Williams would come from Mork and
Mindy with the suspenders on still. And,
um, and, and I, I hear myself talking this
now and it seems like yesterday, yeah,
it seems like yesterday and all of a
sudden we've jettisoned like, you know,
38 years from then and, um, Jay Leno
would ride in and his motorcycle,
um, uh, Richard Lewis packed a lot of
these ex pats would be in the back room,
New Yorkers,
you know,
and then placed the front bar became
a real hangout for a couple of years.
It was like that dance club so hard
with their model that, that was so,
so long ago. Yeah. So I
mean, but, but back in the,
like the early eighties, it became like
a dance hall, you know? Yeah. I mean,
I remember one night, uh, Roy
Scheider came in with, um, um,
pop flossy from all that jazz.
Yeah. You know, I mean the people,
Timothy leary came in one night. Really?
Yeah. The people that came in there,
it was just stacked.
That was a spot that was the spot.
And I was there at that time,
you know, and to see that. Um,
but yeah, there's just so many, well,
it's this cool too because you know that,
you know,
you go into any place now,
there's so many staff that
are like, oh, you know,
like if you're in going to a comedy club,
they're like, I'm, I'm a comic, but I'm,
I'm working here, you know, to pay the
bills. Yeah. Yeah. And that, you know,
but obviously for the majority of, in
any field, it's not going to work out.
It's just the way that that
whole business works. Right.
You're one of the guys where
it really did. It's pretty
well. Yeah. I got to, um, you know,
when you start off doing standup,
you go to as many open Mike nights as
you can and you watch as much comedy as
you can,
you know,
on top of what you've watched growing up
and that she watched everybody's style
and you try to create your own style
and get off the one you were emulating.
You know, when it started,
you know, I was emulating,
well I loved Andy Kaufman and Albert
Brooks and Steve Martin because there are
so different, you know,
they're so unique and yeah,
you really couldn't tell where they're
going with their bits and you were doing
your version of that. I was kind of
doing my version of it. And, and I,
I always like in comics too, I'm like
verbal magicians cause it's misdirection.
Sure. You're not really, you know,
they try to, part of the laughter,
it's a surprise of what
they're about to say, you know,
cause you didn't think about.
So is that where like the subliminal
stuff came from? The subliminal stuff? Uh,
interestingly it came from,
um,
I was getting late night spots
at the comedy store. And, um,
things weren't really working that well
and, um, but I was making friends, um,
at the club and not just comics,
but actors would come in and actors I
would recognize from doing bit parts on
shows like Laverne and Shirley and Mork
and Mindy and happy days, you know,
back then.
And there's this one guy at peck would
come in and he was this tall guy with a
deep voice like that. He did, but he'd
done it. I Lowenbrau commercials and,
and he also played a cop character usually
on a, those, those uh, those TV shows.
And he took a liking to me and, um, we
went to canter's one night and he said,
I'm going to do a thing called
tagging, tagging. He call it tagging.
And it was subliminal base of lay where
he would talk to the waitress and insert
a subliminal word in there when she
wouldn't hear it cause he would bury it,
you know, and, but it would be
real profane, you know, it's
a like, uh, oh, let's see,
how do I think I'm going to have
a cheeseburger, a hooker in,
why don't you also give me Yo some French
fries with it without your dirty whore.
So to me to do with that in my act.
So I started doing that in my,
I love it so much. Thanks man.
And then when I get to SNL,
Al Franken kind of, um, um,
associated with subliminal advertising,
you know,
we thought that would be kind of funny
to write up a sketch where I was a
subliminal advertising guy and you know,
inserting those words into my conversation
to get people to do what I want.
And it was the first sketch I
did an SNL and um, you know,
it's terrifying enough to go on that
show for the first time and do a sketch.
But this one had like two conversations
going on. I don't remember.
I was about to go on,
I'm not sure where it came in the show,
but it was my first sketch and maybe
only sketch on that show and we're five
seconds away coming out of commercial.
And Lauren Michaels comes up next to me.
He puts his arm on my shoulder and he
goes, are you sure this is what you want?
Fuck yeah. But you know, they, it's,
it's funny the way thing people try to
make you feel comfortable before, uh,
a pressure situation, but getting back to
the pussycat theater. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was a bartender at the Improv.
I would usually finish up
about two in the morning,
two 33 o'clock by the time I counted
all the money and made the bank receipts
out.
And then I had to drop the money off at
the bank and a little canvas bag with a
lock on it.
And I did that one night and I was driving
down Melrose to my $135 an apartment
down by paramount down Melrose and in
front of me. It was kind of foggy out,
you know,
and I see this figure walking down the
middle of the street and I was like a
closer,
I see it's a girl and a white dress and
she staggering and she's crying and her
makeup is all running and she's,
she's a massive disheveled mess
and she, I can't, you know,
she's trying to stop my car.
So I slowed down and I put my window
down just a little bit, you know,
cause I don't know what she's
all about it. Yeah. And she, um,
she's crying and she goes,
roll down your window. No.
So I kind of rolled it down
more, you know, and she goes,
they threw me out of the car,
they throw me out of the bastards.
And I said, I'm so sorry. You all right?
She goes, yes. Could you take me to the,
I think it was a pussycat theater was a
kit Kat club. It was a strip club maybe.
I said, oh, okay. And she
gets in the car, big mistake.
And I don't know where the Kit Kat
theater, there was one on Melrose.
I thought that's where she wanted to
go cause I would go buy it all the time
going home. But she wanted to
go to the one on Santa Monica,
I guess there was one. And
uh, and we're driving and uh,
so I get her to the, uh, the one on
Melrose. I say, here you go, because, no,
that's not the one. She's drunk,
you know, and, and she goes,
I'm seeing I'm a, and now
I'm thinking, Oh, this is a
mistake. I said, you know what,
I, I, I, I'm gonna have to let you
out here. She goes, I have a gun.
I said, we're on Santa
Monica, is it? Exactly.
But I dropped her off and she kind of
fell out of the car and I ran around and
picked her up and got her on the
sidewalk. I mean, it will look bad
for me, like if I'm dropping her off,
like I was like her kicking her out.
Yeah. She blames me. That
guy. That's so, yeah.
So when you said the pussycat theater,
I thought that maybe that was
my mother going on a date with a man.
Like in the 80s she was single
and she went on a date with a guy.
Your mom partied like taxi taxi driver,
want to go see a porno movie again. Yeah.
So there's a lot of movies like
that. He's like, what? He's so crazy.
It took you to a movie. My mom dated
this guy for like 10 years after.
So obviously it was a good thing.
Yeah, of course. Yeah, I was so,
I was so influenced by the tagging
and subliminal thing in class.
I used to be like, um, so if you can,
we carry the four there
with the nipple that,
and I would say it like that and like
just my friend next to me would like turn
it. She would never came, you know?
And then she'd be like, yes, of course.
I was like, oh. Then people would start
because they would hear it, you know?
But like she would never pick up on it. I
love that stuff. It's such a funny word.
That's a great word to use.
Nipple.
I know like a Carl Reiner Mel
Brooks were talking about,
or maybe it's crawl around and talking
about, they had to have a number.
I could some script for maybe the
Dick Van Dyke show or something.
Your show of shows maybe.
And they were trying to think of what the
funniest number was to say and I think,
I'm not sure what it is, but I think
he said 43 is the funniest. No,
43 60
is the funniest number. I
think so, but I'm not sure.
But it sounds like 40 maybe 43 45
45 is the funniest Irish numbers.
45 for sure.
Tom and I did this thing where when we
go through the Starbucks drive through
and then you go in your order,
you can call people mommy like wage were
waitresses are people and they don't
even pick up on it. People
ended up taking, so this
is our game was to go like,
hey mommy and orders about bucks and then
at the end go, thanks jeans. I love you.
Thanks. Thanks jeans. It's like a name. So
thanks genes love you. And they're like,
all right,
two 65 at the window.
And then we started to tell our audience
about it. And the whole thing was like,
could you, how many? Cause
there's so many inside jokes,
like its own lexicon in
this, in this show. Um,
that like how many could you get it?
And people,
like we played a girl one time
who was definitely disturbed, um,
and she would, uh, she would say
hi to Hitler before she played she,
before she spoke at the blog to Hitler.
Yeah. That's not a touret thing.
That would be horrible to have that
Tourette's syndrome. Like, yeah,
this was like, that would be
a bad one. But, but anyways,
people would go in and go
like, uh, or the n word.
Yeah. Well we did have a documentary
about that. Some girl did say that.
Big Words we did, she was, she would go
to summer camp and say that more. Yeah.
I'll tell you that.
You know,
I have a real problem with drive for is
I cannot resist like doing some screwy
character. Oh, you know what? I'm ordering
and even if nobody else was in the car,
you know, I get in there, hey,
let it tell you. I'll, let me see.
I go into AA though to ice cream called
ca one chuck a day and then one of that
ne and beat. Okay. That's
it. Nothing to drink.
Okay, so he's thinking of the vanilla and
the chocolate chocolate. That didn't a,
I took all to wine,
the white one brown and then I'll drive
through and they'll hand it to me and
I'll go with which one? One is a
chocolate though. Which one is chocolate?
And they'll point it. It's this one
here, sir. Right here. Dot Brown.
Thank you mommy.
It was really the most people start when
we started sharing that we did this.
People started to make them like record
themselves doing it and they would throw
in the fucking most insane requests.
And the thing that stood out to us
is that those drive through people.
So many of them are on autopilot though.
No matter what you're saying,
they're just like, yes sir.
You got it. Got It. Yeah, sure.
This is a Hitler's order here.
You go give it to him. It's a,
the fries are still hot.
Yeah. That's the great
thing about Starbucks too.
You could write anything on that cup name.
Oh yeah,
I was trying to find that. Yeah, thanks.
Jeans kind of sounds like it's
a regional kind of a thing.
Someone might say like a Minnesota
or something, you know. Thanks jeans.
Thanks James. Found it.
I think this is it. Okay.
Can I get a
[inaudible]?
Hi Mommy. Mommy. Mommy. Mommy.
What's Your Pronoun? Uh, yeah. One
second. I'm just glass and look for last.
Hi Mommy. Can I get up like
second? She's on a sub came Bagel.
No thanks. I don't want to be found
like Bert. Excuse me one second.
Sorry about that.
Can you do just a little bit of ice and
I'm talking about filming real stuff
and they kiss my pussy chicken
if
you know what I'm sorry.
Could we make it Combo?
Thanks James. Thanks genes.
All right, thank you Hitler.
That's great. Thank you. It's
my pussy chicken might be,
it's so crazy. Good subliminal
rather. Yeah, it is right. Oh Man.
That's the best influence that,
I mean when we really think about it,
you definitely influenced that.
That's fun.
Um,
it was just thinking something like the
drive through, so, yeah, it's crazy.
There's people work all the time,
so they're not thinking
no. Yeah, no, that was just like,
yeah, cause my posts chicken shirt.
Yeah.
Which is all by the way things that like
we have a lady who was in the bank and
she,
she just yells out like,
I want my money got damaged and then she
goes kiss my pussy like in Wells Fargo.
So we had that drop that would just
play for a while. So people would just,
that's hilarious. I remember the
original submission he goes, gets,
I put plus a chicken and she goes,
Kung Pao chicken. Oh yeah. Right.
So they think like, like he
must be trying to say, um,
so you've, you've been
working for awhile. Uh,
do you have any advice for Johnny
Depp? Um, for Johnny Depp? Yeah.
So I don't know if you are
familiar with what's going on.
You read about that or no? Yeah, I think
so. $650 million he's earned thus far.
He bursts through a lot of cash. I
mean, they said he's nearly broke.
He spends in excess of 2 million a month.
Wow. Yeah. Well, you know,
when you're at his level and you've
had that much money, I mean, you know,
it's like when you start making money,
right?
You stop looking at what things cost,
right. Pushing them in a restaurant.
You know, when you're just
starting out, you're like, oh,
that's $12 I can get this for
$8 I'll have the $8. Right.
Or I'll just order off the menu and
not do the buffet. Right. Right.
But so I guess at his
level, he's, it's so long.
He knows he's made a lot of money and
he's just a little bit at a time you start
spending left and right.
It's like compulsive. They said
it's like a disorder. Well,
what were some of the
things you listed like, oh,
he shot hunter s Thompson's
ashes into the data. Yeah. Yeah.
My friend,
you know,
Dana Carvey says his biggest fear in
life would be how horrible it would be to
be famous and broke. Oh yeah.
It's gotta be Oh yeah. Yeah.
And he's not famous broke, but he, that's,
that was a thing he thought about a lot.
Yeah.
Were you like really when you started
to make money where you very, um,
you know, aware? Like I gotta
Save, I gotta keep this or
you. Yeah. Yeah. No, cause
I, you know, I,
I grew up in a middle income
household and we weren't poor,
but we lived in a blue collar neighborhood
and stuff and I went to public
schools. It's mostly high school. I went
to a private school, but, um, you know,
I paid for my own college,
bought my own first car and stuff.
So I kind of knew the value of money
and worked in a factory and yeah,
you don't wash dishes, all those
kind of jobs. So I kind of like,
and that's what I want
to still my kid too.
Like I hope he didn't have to
work the crappy jobs I did. Right.
But I want them to know the value
of money. Yeah. Yeah. So, um,
I'm always kind of aware you are.
Yeah.
Oh wait, but being famous
and broke, that's what being
on a reality show is like,
right. It was that in the 90s I did a
show called road rules back when MTV was,
you know,
MTV and it was terrible because people
could just have access to you and they're
like,
hey,
you're the fucking girl from Silento and
you have no money to like protect her,
insulate yourself from anybody.
Yeah. I like being a reality star.
The Look, you know, I still look at
prices and still doing it, but you know,
I don't spend, um, crazily, I
still buy things that I like.
I don't want sure.
I'm pretty good with the
money. It is. There's nothing,
I don't know if you think about this,
but the longer you do this and you have
like some exposure to some success,
the more you look at people who've done
it for a long time and you're like, man,
how do they do that for so long? Like
the fact that you've been, you know,
working and creating stuff for this
long, it's amazing to me. It's amazing.
Me Too. You know, I, I, um, but
the thing is I love doing it.
I love what I do. So it's
not, it's not hard. You know,
I'm always looking for things.
I'm just trying to,
trying to stay engaged and I've,
you know,
I've just talking to somebody about this
before, I know a couple of billionaires.
Do you? Yeah. And there, you know,
like billions of dollars and they
are really good with their money.
They're not like, you know,
they're, I won't say they're cheap,
but they're very kind of thrifty,
you know,
and they know they're not going to just
throw away a bunch of money to invest in
some film or something. You
know what I mean? Yeah. Um,
they know where it's going and that's how
they became billionaires, I guess. Oh,
yeah.
Yeah. Well, Johnny Depp would, uh,
invest like 4 million. And, um,
so here's the record label. Here's how,
here's some of the spending. Yeah. Let's,
yeah, he lost four. First of all, I paid
5.6 million in late fees to the IRS,
which he blames the business manager for,
but the business manager says they were
always late because he never had enough
cash to pay on time so that cause he was
ripping through cash so much that they
would always be late and have to
pay penalties and fees. Hmm. Uh,
over 30,000 a month in wine you
learn about that. Makes Sense. Yeah.
He said that was more than
that. Don't insult them. Yeah.
He said don't assault him. Um, let's
see. Court documents filed last year.
You claimed the actress spent,
uh,
around a hundred million on
maintaining his 14 residences,
which include a 45 acre
chateau in the south of France,
chain of islands in The Bahamas,
multiple homes in Hollywood,
several Penthouse lofts,
downtown La Horse Farm in Kentucky.
He went to Singapore,
Singapore and spent 120,000 on suits.
Well, in Singapore. Really? Is that
the place you get the suits? Yeah.
Get them handmade.
Maybe a,
he's collected 70 of vintage guitars.
He has 14,
um,
storage facilities for like
Hollywood memorabilia here.
It's good that he got divorced because
his wife has saving half of his money.
Right.
He'll have to remarry her later and at
least still have some kind of a savings.
It's 3 million for Shah
firing the, uh, the rocket of,
uh, uh, what's it called? Hunter
has taught his ashes into the sky,
which he said something he needed to do.
Yeah.
Now he a depth that it wasn't 3 million
was actually 5 million. Oh my goodness.
200 piece art collection, which
yeah, I get why you would do that.
He apparently spends as much as 200,000
a month just on chartering flights,
uh,
worth every penny,
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
to employ a full time sound engineer to
feed him lines during filming.
Oh, 45 cars he bought.
Uh, yeah. I Dunno, it just
kinda goes on and on. Yeah.
The storage facilities, it's like,
it's hundreds of thousands. He's uh,
he has a personal doctor. I like that.
I'd spend money on that million a year
to live with you then I do a Mizzou.
Yeah.
2 million a year annually
for around the clock.
Security for himself and his
mother prior to her death.
I would hire somebody just to
remind me of my passwords. Yeah,
that would be great idea.
Um, and let's see. Oh, Anna,
40 person staff that he keeps up
with more than 43 million a year.
Yeah. So it really is really
crazy that you can read it
through that much money.
I'm more amazed at how it's gotta be crazy
to be that attractive and that famous
for that long like, yeah.
When he was on 21 jump street,
w what was he like maybe 18 years old or
something. Yeah. And like he's the guy,
like I had a poster on my wall,
like a life size poster of that dude.
He's been hot for that long.
I know that's going to be crazy.
How are you even normal,
I can tell you from my experience.
Yeah.
You just got to come out with creative
posters. Yeah. That's what it is.
It's not that hard. Just be in
that hot. Still hot. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm still hot. I haven't even
peaked yet. How much was it a thing,
an SNL to like translate the fame
of it to crushing box all the time?
Like especially in New York,
like would you guys just be
on a tear cause you were on,
I think everyone has an era.
Yeah.
Kind of that they follow the most
depending on their age. Yeah. Yeah.
Depending on your age.
Cause like I couldn't list,
I couldn't tell you the
last 10 cast of that show,
but I know the,
especially the early to mid nineties
cast real well because that was the era
that I never missed. That was must
see TV and when you were on a,
but you were on with like
if I can Farley's Sandler
rock and all those guys were
on during your era. Right, right.
I was chasing tail like a big
part of life for you guys. Uh,
for those guys it was for Sandler and
really and those guys. Yeah. But I was,
you know, I think, um, by then I was
married. Oh you were? Okay. I mean,
the first couple of years I wasn't
married. I was dating Jan Hooks. Yeah.
For a couple of years. Yeah. And
then I was dating another girl in La.
I'm in New York for like six months,
and then I got married, you know,
so I didn't really have that much, a
singular freedom, you know, on that show.
Marrying kind. I am, I really am.
I like that kind of stability.
I like monogamy. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, but Kevin leads with it.
I mean, when I met him he was like,
just so you know, I'm married. Okay.
All right. What, what kind of jobs did
you have before you were to stand up?
Okay. Um, right before I moved out here,
I was a researcher for America's most
wanted the television show. Where are you?
Yeah, so I any research that,
so they would just give you, um,
you know, potential. You've heard
this story before and she's like out,
so they'll give you potential crimes
or crimes and potential suspects,
find out more. And then you pitch the, um,
basically the editor of the
show. Uh, not like editor,
like written editor, but you know,
like the, like the, like the,
like a newspaper, editors, stylists,
bullpen. And we would pitch this guy,
I guess he's an executive producer. So we
would just go like, Hey, I got this guy,
he's a fucking rapist. He's in
Costa Rica. He skipped out on bail.
Could be really good.
Like it was really dark stuff.
I read his whole diary. He's
really fucking horrible. Yeah,
I think we should do this one.
And then you try to make your
case for why it would be a good,
a good guy to profile. I did that for a,
when did you make money on commission?
They got him. You get points?
No. So that was um, that was,
I dunno that was but as it like a teenager
or you're early. Oh, I mean I did.
Uh, I, I remember I was telling
her the other day, cause they're,
they're redoing a bathroom
here and they're going to
put some Thailand and I go,
man, when I was, uh,
in, in high school, my,
my friend's dad bought these
apartments are like a shitty area.
And this is in Florida,
south Florida.
In the summer we had to relay tile in
all of them with no air conditioning.
In the summertime. It was fucking
brutal, man. Mosquitoes. I did that. Um,
I worked at Granger,
the industrial supply place in college,
just doing menial office stuff.
Yeah. Then when I got out here,
I was at transcriber for reality shows.
You transcribed everything.
Someone says you're a good typist. I mean,
I'm okay. I don't know. It's a fucking,
it's not worth celebrating.
Then I was opposed coordinator.
Then I worked at a restaurant
for a little while, um,
on sunset place called Chibo.
I worked there for a little while,
then a cheapo cheap Chibo Chibo Kibo.
Then it was a site rep, which was
actually one of the, it's a site Rep.
So let's say you own,
um,
what of your house and you're like, I
want, oh, that would be great. Uh, you go,
I want production to be able to
shoot here. Oh, I see. Yeah. Yeah.
So when you do that,
the company that represents your house
sends a rep to make sure the production
doesn't destroy your house because they
will. I know, I know. And like I would,
I would be working in a
fucking historically protected
church and I'd see a guy
like, no. Oh, like nailing into the wall.
What the fuck are you doing? He's like,
we need the hand in this fucking light
here. I'm like, dude, you can't nail.
And they would just always play stupid.
And I'd run around and
like try to tell somebody,
don't let that guy do they like the
SAG representative. It was horrible.
There's a house, my neighborhood where
they're always shooting commercials there.
Yeah. I know that thing's got
to be just torn up by the horn.
But they pay well when you get the
real productions in there. Yeah.
But they also protect it a lot.
They put a lot of that stuff
down on the floor too. But,
but I've worked in homeless before.
Other people's homes. Um, you know. Yeah.
I'm using their bathroom. I'm
not using the Porta potty. No.
I step over that yellow crime
tape thing for sure. Yeah.
People don't give a fuck man now.
And then it's put the best business
is when you own a building.
So that was really a home.
But just a building and it's perfect for
shooting for whatever reason. Oh my God.
They rake it in. Oh, I'm sure now
it's like you just get like a fee,
like your talent for your building.
Maybe we can make a lot of money by just
building a building that was perfect
for a lot of different shoots. Why don't
we do that? What are we waiting for?
One of those who do you
know the guy crazy Gideon?
Yeah. He owns two buildings in
downtown La that I've shot stuff in.
And it is that they're like,
it's a huge building full of different
is that you're talking about, sorry,
different scenarios. Like
one's like a cop. Remember the,
was it the Herald or the,
the uh,
they used to be a newspaper building
downtown and then they have building sets
in there and then to
the year had that big,
that big building down there
by the freeway. So you could,
you could actually use the,
the old school newspaper bullpen look.
Then they built a fake courthouse in
their jail cell. All these things.
I shot a movie called Grandma's boy
down there. Oh yeah. That building.
That was part of it. That's where the
money is, man. What are we waiting for?
How are we doing this stupid joke.
Shit suck away. Before I forget,
are we managers? Oh my God, I love it.
Managers like it was funny
because I went to her taping,
she did a Netflix thing a few weeks
ago and I show up and I'm like, oh,
when you're not recording but
you're at one of these things,
you never feel the stress. You know? Like
I showed up and she was like, she's like,
Hey, you know, I'm just going over my
stuff. I'm like, it's fucking great.
I enjoy it. You don't have
fun talking like managers to
look. You don't feel it at
all. Yeah. Yeah. That's it.
Just have fun out there and be
yourself, Kevin. So when you did SNL,
I dunno, where does it hit you? When you
get nervous, like what do you do? Well,
here's
what my psychology was on that show.
The first time I did it,
the year we came on,
I came on with Phil Hartman and Dana
Carvey and Jan Hooks in North Korea.
Although seen those people.
Yeah. And I'm heavy hitters.
The show before that also had a good cast,
but the synergy wasn't
there with the writing.
You know what it looks like Robert Downey,
Jr Anthony Michael Hall,
I think Julia Louise Dreyfus.
You know, it was a great cast,
but the writing was in there and the show
was plummeting and there were about to
cancel it.
Excuse me.
So they brought our cast in as kind of
a last resort, I guess. One more chance.
And so we lived at of our suitcases,
like every week.
We weren't sure if it was getting
a cancel or not, you know,
so we're doing our best and
this was a consideration for me.
Am I going to like just freak out
because of the stress and being on stage.
It's SNL, you know? So what I did was,
excuse me, I, I pretended that nobody
was watching the show anymore. You know,
nobody's going to watch it and this is
going to be the only show they're going
to do. Then they're going
to cancel it. So, you know,
just go out there and have fun.
So that was my mindset and I thought the
cameras and didn't have film in them,
you know,
and um,
and I was used to playing in front of
a live audience from stand up and that
audience is not that big there.
It's only like 300 people.
And so it was kind of fine.
And then the next day I found out a lot
of people watch. Yeah. Was that, um,
was there a particular
sketch where you realize, um,
the next day or the next week that, oh,
this has made me way more famous? Like,
cause you're walking around
people are, well, yeah. Um,
it was my first sketches
subliminal. Oh, subliminal. Yeah.
I just came out of the gate with
that and I wasn't even a cast member.
I was a featured player the first
year and a writer. So, you know,
I was walking around with Jan Hooks
who was amazing, you know, sketch,
player, impressionist,
everything. I really,
I mean she's right up on the top of the
list right there for everybody that's
been on that show and people
weren't recognizing her.
And I was getting recognized last stand
up who had no experience as a cast,
you know, as a, you know, a sketch
player, characters or anything, you know,
and I was getting recognized. So that kind
of was baffling her a little bit. Yeah,
it was a good sketch.
Then there was a good sketch
and people thought it was funny.
Was fever pitch of fame
from that doing like the uh,
well obviously we can update.
It's gotta make you,
you're in people's face and came later.
For me though, I had done like a,
I had done
five years at that point without
doing weekend update. Oh, okay.
I did a weekend update for three years
and then a year not doing it, but um,
it,
it was interesting to watch the um,
the evolution of being
recognized, you know? Sure.
Cause I had done like the tonight show
and let her minute stuff as a standup.
So I had some recognition but with
Carson, yeah. When I got an SNL though,
it was like, um, it just took off,
especially in New York City. You know,
you kind of felt like the mayor, but
you know it, it went from this like uh,
uh, a u. Dot dude from NBC. Hey, did not
do what you got dude from Mec. Right?
And the next week, Hey, uh, hey, you've
frozen hands. You guys are Hans and Franz.
That sounds frons I'm just
standing there alone. Hey,
your hands in friends and
then it's a a Kevin Neilson
SNL or, and then it was Kevin Nealon
and now it's back the other way.
Oh my God. We did it on the
school yard hunts and Friday.
A lot of people on Halloween costumes and
stuff we're doing in the space shuttle
that that is the era where we
would go to school on Monday.
It would be, people would be reciting
sketches. That sketch in particular.
I was like, that's exactly why when
I was doing, we can update people.
I really didn't like to write
for weekend update the key,
the writers didn't like to write
specifically for weekend update because it
wasn't a glorified job like a Monday.
Nobody was talking about, hey,
did you hear about that? Do you get that?
Push to go to Clinton joke, you know,
and so they had to entice them
to come write jokes for me.
They would put out a breakfast spread
like a buffet in the writer's wing on
Saturday morning and they'd
have newspapers all over
the big writers' table and
you know, and AP photos cause there's
no Google back then, you know. So,
um, I feel by the way that it's super
intimidating of all the things to do,
weekend update. It is, it really
is a lot of pressure. Right.
There's a lot of pressure. Uh, but
people would come up, you know,
a few writers would come up,
the newer writers would come
up who weren't that good.
And then some of the other writers,
like Al Frank would always come because
he was such a political junkie, you know,
and um,
and Norm Mcdonald would come up,
but he would come up just to have
breakfast and read the paper. And then,
so I had to like hire people outside the
show to fax me in jokes and I would pay
them out of my own pocket. 15. Yeah.
And I mean it was important to
me to do and we can update and a,
and then I write my own jokes too.
But you couldn't,
you really couldn't start looking to
write material until Friday night.
Maybe after the late night
talk shows were done, you know,
cause they are recovering everything.
So Saturday morning it's like you wake
up and you get like five papers and you
start looking through them and you
start writing jokes and you know,
and hope that the writers
come up with something.
Now that did it because you
were busy with weekend update,
would that buy you the freedom to not
have to do like if you're like no.
I was also writing sketches for myself.
Hey Man. And I was in another sketches.
Dennis did a great job,
uh,
Miller and we can update did it I think
for seven years and he was fantastic but
he wasn't really in a lot of sketches.
He was, we could focus on that.
I was juggling,
you know,
I wasn't my full focus and I was working
with herb Sargent who was a segment
producer of that show and he was
up at a seven, you know, and, um,
and I would meet with him like a in
between, um, the dress rehearsal,
showing a live show and go over the
jokes that worked. It didn't work and,
you know, and then I had to get back
down to like working on my sketch and,
and so I go back out to weekend update
during the live show and some of the
jokes that we had talked about losing,
we're still in there because he didn't
cause either he wrote them or he liked
them.
And,
and I didn't really realize it until
the next morning I'm laying in bed,
kind of going over everything,
you know,
and taking the chuck
wasn't supposed to be,
so he knew that I was not focused and
he could do kind of wow sometimes.
Not all the time, but sometimes he would
do that. Yeah. Yeah. So it was, um,
but it was fun. I loved it. I loved,
um, Saturday nights were just,
they went so fast,
you know,
and I always avoided like the parties
at the after parties. You did? Yeah.
At first they were fun,
but then it became more of just them a
thing for your guests to go to. I got you.
Because you were exhausted from work
and you didn't want to be out till like
five in the morning. And as I must say,
yeah, they must be tilt late. Oh yeah.
Because you know,
you don't get there until after the show
and the show ends at one o'clock and
then by the time your clean up and
everything and getting the limos,
we each had our own limit.
It would take us to this
different restaurant each
night. He'd Saturday and then,
you know,
cause that was a big deal for your
friends that were in the guests or the
biggest problem on that show,
you worried about them getting their seats
when you should have been focusing on
your sketch or whatever. Yeah, you were,
did they get it? Okay. Are they in okay.
You're okay. You can't
go good. All right. Yeah,
I'm gonna meet you down by the
Limo afterwards. Okay. Okay.
We're going to go to the park. And then
the parties weren't even really parties.
I mean, they were fun, but you know, it
was at a restaurant and you go there,
you sit at your own table with your guests
and their necks were crane the whole
night looking, um, you know, celebrities.
And then you pay the bill for everybody
and then you get home at like four in
the morning and then you, you're
wasted on Sunday. You're only free day.
I'm always curious about it.
Sunday is your one down day and
you must just collapse on a Sunday.
Right. And like to even get out of bed,
I get out of bed. Yeah. Because, um,
because I, I, I love that it's a free
day and I want, I don't want to waste it,
you know, but I'm exhausted, you
know. And the next thing, you know,
it's Monday evening in your meeting
with the next host for the show the next
week. It is. But it was great. I had fun.
You know, I was young at the time and I,
I could, I could handle it. Did
you have a least favorite, uh,
guests that you don't mind?
I didn't like any of them really.
I'm not really, everybody was really on
their best behavior. People ask me that,
who is the worst house?
But everybody is terrified and so
they're on their best behavior. Right.
And they want to be your friend.
So they're making friends.
It's like you were like,
you know,
in the battle somewhere with
somebody you want to, hey,
watch out for my back though.
That must be so intimidated to walk in.
And they're like, you're doing
SNL this week. Oh, I know.
Especially the actors that weren't
used to live performing. Sure.
Like the film actors, they were
terrified, some of them. And um,
I felt for them.
But the first one I did was with Sigourney
weaver who very first one, first one.
And um, and I remember a such a hard
week as so much work because you know,
you're putting everything into
it. You want to, you know,
it's like your last show
you're ever going to do.
And I remember at the end of the week
she was saying goodbye to everybody and I
thought, wow, she gets to go on with their
life and do things. Yeah. Stay in here.
Yeah. The week like that, nine,
nine years of those now I,
yeah, Matt on them. That's my mom. Yeah.
Yeah.
But you know,
when I see those people that hosted
every one of them from those nine years,
even that, some of the musicians were
like best buddies. It's like they,
they remember the value because it was
such a moment for them. Sure. You know,
a bonding, um, just everybody
that's been on that show,
it's like a lifelong friend. Where before
I forget, you're going to San Francisco.
I'm going to cobb's in San Francisco.
This is it this week. This weekend.
So how was San Francisco last week?
I'll be at the helium.
Funny. I'll be at the helium, uh, what's
it called? Them Comedy Club Portland.
I'll be at the helium comedy club in
Philadelphia. Affiliates is a great one.
Yeah. When is that? That is
going to be, I can pull it up.
You could edit this.
Yeah. Yeah. Let me see,
Kevin. It's Kevin Neilson. Uh,
it's the guy from SAP, from SNL,
NBC, and we say, yeah, let me see.
He's going to be there August 9th,
10th and 11th.
Um,
that's Kevin, this is you,
right? Yeah. Kevin Nealon. Uh,
and I tell 11th and then in
Annapolis the next day. Yeah.
Ram's head onstage. What's that? Yes
sir. It's a theater. It's really nice.
They have one to key west to check
you out. Check it out, right? Yeah.
Before I forget though, you have to tell
us about Carson and what that was like.
Oh, I feel like it's comics. We
got gypped on the late night.
We didn't get to do anything. Well,
when I first started doing standup,
Johnny Carson was the game in town.
You know,
he was really the only late night
talk show and that's what you, uh,
you know,
wanting to do.
And that's like passing your bar exam
as a lawyer, you know, for a comic.
So everybody wanted to get on the tonight
show with Johnny and it was getting
near the end of his run. So, you know,
everybody's getting a little desperate,
you know, they wanted to get in the
door at least when I came on the scene.
And so Jim Mccauley was the talent
coordinator at the time and he would come
into the clubs, he'd be around the clubs,
you know, watch them, different people.
Whenever he was in the room there was
a heightened anxiety because the comics
knew that he was there and some people
would cancel because they didn't want him
to see him. Wow. Or someone what tried
to get on so they could see him. Yep.
And I think I auditioned may be
twice for him or I didn't make it.
And I was so nervous. I'd only
been doing standup for, you know,
four or five years. And I had sweat
running down the back of my legs.
I was so nervous and I never could
pass the audition for the tonight show.
And He, did he give you
notes? Sometimes he did,
sometimes he did. Awesome. He
didn't really for me though.
But I remember at the Improv at the time,
if you were on the tonight show,
everybody would be in the club that
night and they'd be watching it on the TV
over the bar, you know, just the
one TV and the room would get quiet.
You know, you bring up the comic who
would be working at the end problem,
you know,
it was a regular and the comic come out
and people would just be cheering and
they'd be applauding. Wow. So
I auditioned again for him,
but it was for another show
is for the Mike Nesmith show.
The guy from the monkeys,
you know the band,
he was a producer and I thought, well,
this time, and it was Jim Mccauley,
that same talent coordinator.
Um,
it was casting for the Mike Nesmith
show and also the tonight show.
So I thought I'm going to do the material,
I think makes me laugh for then I notice
Michelle and I don't care about Jim
McKellar. There's tonight show and I get
a call from them the next day saying,
good news and bad news.
Uh,
the bad news is we don't think you're
right for the mezze Mike Nesmith show,
but we loved your set and we'd love for
you to do the tonight show with Johnny
Carson. And I almost dropped the
phone. Really? Can you do it on Monday?
This was Friday and I was going on my
way to Houston to do a comedy club there
that weekend. And um, so you know,
you've got to do five minutes.
So I would do my five minutes,
like in front of my real
set and all I would do 24,
seven for those three days was go over
my act over and over and I could be
talking to you now. You think I'm
listening to you. You're nodding.
I'm going over my act in my head and I
invented the tonight show a lot of times
when it first came out to la,
I would go there because the
tickets were free and I knew the,
I knew the routine.
You go to the guest relations building,
they'll give you a ticket and you
come back at three 30 you get in line.
And it was like watching a Vegas show.
I mean,
I saw so many people that I knew exactly
what the format was. I knew that Fred,
to carve it, a producer would
come out and talk to the audience.
Doc Severinsen would come out, you know,
I knew that the song the band played,
Johnny would come out and say a quick
hi and then they start the show.
So I knew exactly what I was getting into.
Smart of you to do that.
So you weren't nervous for well as
nervous as nervous maybe. But um,
so Monday rolls along and
I, I, I am, I'm white.
I'm driving out to the tonight
show. I can't believe it, like park.
And I see Johnny's car parked in his
spot there right by the entrance.
I walked by it and my heart's
just like beating like crazy.
And I go to my dressing room and I
get into my, my, you know, my suit,
my jacket and tie and I go into makeup
and Johnny stops in real quick and he
wishes me good luck
and I can't believe it.
That was Johnny Carson and
now Jim Macaulay's there,
they talent coordinator and a behind
the curtain. I know the band is playing.
I know every member of that band cause
I watched them so many times and they're
coming back from commercial about to
bring me out and Johnny introduces me and
the curtain opens up and they're
applauding and I go blank.
I can't think of the opening line at all.
I don't remember any material.
And I'm walking out and I know the
floor is shiny black, you know,
and the band is finished and yeah,
there's still saliva dripping out of
the trombone players instrument and,
and they're applauding still.
And I'm standing on my mark and the
last clap and it came back to me and I
started doing my act and I started
getting laughs. Laughs, applaud breaks,
you know,
laughs.
And I hear Johnny laughing at Ed
Mcmahon back there over my shoulder.
I don't look though, cause
that's not cool. And I'm,
and I'm thinking to myself as I'm
doing my, I'm on the tonight show,
I'm doing the tonight show and I know
my material so well, you know, by rote.
I don't even have to think about it.
I'm just doing it and I'm
thinking I'm on the tonight show,
I'm on the tonight show.
And it ends in the applauds and it,
and it was supposed to be five minutes,
but because there's so much applaud
breaks and it went like eight minutes and
I'd get behind the curtain. Johnny gave
me the, you know, the signal, great job.
And I go behind the
curtain and I'm thinking,
I did the tonight show and Jim
Macaulay's back there all smiles.
He did you great, you did great.
Happy. I think Johnny's don't go, wait,
Jonny I think wants to talk to you because
it went a little long and they don't
have time for the last guest.
So he wants you to come out to the panel
and he goes, what can we talk about?
And I felt like saying, get out of
my wage, Johnny wants to talk to me,
I don't need you anymore. But he
goes, oh, don't worry about it.
You've got plenty of stuff.
So I went out there and had extra stuff
that I hadn't talked about and it was
like, I was like in heaven,
I never had experienced this
before. Nothing like that.
Even with, that's Anelle and
weeds, any of those shows.
And I'm sitting there and I'm doing,
he's setting me up perfectly
without even having any, you know,
questions they just fell into place.
That's how great he was.
And I remember him throwing his
head back, laughing, a little smoke,
still coming out from a cigarette,
from the break, you know,
and for 30 years of smoking,
you know,
and I got off of this
show and I was floating.
I felt like I was injected with some
kind of a drug that has never been
experienced before. And it was a
natural high. I've never had that again,
but you know,
I went home or to my friends house so
I used to write with and we just waited
and we just, we sat there with smiles on
our face, you know, just smile, smiles.
And then it aired and I watched it
with a pillow in front of my head,
but I knew everybody was
at the Improv watching.
Like I used to watch everybody else and
I still have the answering machine tape
from my answering machine now.
All the comics that called afterwards and
all the people that Kinda got in touch
and you got the couch, you got
applause break. Not only that,
I started dating the girl that I
bumped the actuaries on after me.
Really? Yes. For six months we dated.
It was like a home run in every way,
but he had never kind of like took
me on such an emotional story.
It was, like I said to this day,
it was the highlight of my day.
I literally froze for a moment.
You were about to say and I can
remember and then I couldn't do stand up
the fuck are you doing,
I was so scared that you,
but you know at that time you didn't even
have like bullet points on a cute card
next. Totally let you do now give
you a cue cards for your act.
You just, and I had, I didn't even
have my in my pocket, you know,
I was just going,
I'll sell with this. The uh, one
of the Times I did stand up on,
I think it was on Conan and maybe the
first time when I was behind the curtain,
I go,
how much time do I have?
And I meant before I,
they bring me out.
So the guy, no, the guy goes, oh, he goes,
he wants to know how much time he has.
And I see him radio it, he goes, you
have like five minutes. And I'm like,
all right. So I'm like, I have five
minutes to stand here and contemplate.
I was starting to get like,
you know, anxiety five minutes.
And then I just hear like, and he's
like, ladies, gentlemen, my next guest.
And I was like, Hey motherfucker, you
just said five minutes. She's like, no,
you're right now. Right now.
And then, but it was like,
it threw me into walking out
with like a panic, you know?
But it was okay because I don't know,
I was able to just kind of regroup.
But I remember thinking like,
I have five minutes to stand here and I
have yet ruined like 10 seconds later.
That's a surprise.
I thought it was gonna go the other way.
How much time do I have? You got
two minutes. Oh, two minutes.
I thought they said fine. Then you cut it
short. I could did a minute and a half.
That would have been horrible.
I'm so envious of you though to have
that because that really is like the,
that was it easy to get Carson
and tell the couch and to,
to make it through that hoop is like
great thrill for me. And I don't know
how many times I did that show. I mean,
some people know exactly
like Tom Driessen,
they know exactly what the tonight show.
And I don't know how many times I did
it. And I, I did it with a lot of guests,
the hosts too. And I think, I think
he stopped having me on his show.
Yeah.
After one of my appearances there
because I didn't know he had a Dui,
you know? Yeah. And I came out, it
was around the holidays. I said,
my opening joke was, I'm getting ready
for the holidays. I don't know about you,
but I'm getting ready for the holidays.
I've been doing a lot of
drinking and driving, you know,
and I finished my set and
then, um, now there would be,
by the way, a think piece about
Kevin. Yeah. But Jim Mccauley,
that coordinator calls me, he
goes, oh, I w the opening joke, um,
we didn't go over that. I
said, Oh yeah, I believe me.
I know I don't throw anything in at the
last minute. That was part of the set.
He goes, yeah, that was, you know,
cause I, when I watched it, they,
they gobbled it all up. Okay.
Did my opening joke, it says,
I don't know about you guys,
but I'm getting ready for the holidays
I've been doing with Albert Liberal.
I'll Laura what? I thought, what was that?
Okay.
And, and then I find out that
Johnny had a DUI and you know,
there's a lot of problems with that and I,
and I don't specifically remember,
but I, that may have been my
last time on the tonight show.
He was, I mean they, there was a,
a number of stories about
how you don't cross him.
He would like Joan Rivers in any way.
It perceived,
yeah. Believe me, had I known
he had a Dui, it never would
have done that, you know,
but, um, but I don't even like to,
I cringe when I think about it.
The conversation you might've had with
McAlary afterwards, you know, my idol,
like say, what the hell was that all
about? You know? Right. Well look,
speaking of smiles,
I got a fucking,
oh my goodness.
Yeah, we're kind of obsessed with dental
care. Yeah. You have a very nice smile.
Thank you.
I know that you know that already.
I know it because I've been
in the dentist's chair for
half of my life. Really?
Yeah. Really tell us about dental stuff.
Oh. Oh. I've had, you know, when I,
my teeth came in when I was
eight, I fell on a, you know,
a payment and I've broken both
all brown. Oh. So I've had like,
you know, crowns on the front. Really?
Yeah. Yeah. So that, and uh, you know,
I've had six root canals, six
two implants last year. God,
yes.
I've been in the dentist's chair a lot.
Which teeth are root canal
does it Moore's back?
Mostly molars in the back of then one
of the front ones. Cause I can kill it.
You know, I died, I died. So these
two are fake. Well the, the crowns,
the crowns. Yeah. Little nubs
underneath them. Yeah. Really good.
I remember when you got your, they
up. Do you down remember when? Yeah.
I got nubs to these front two or veneers
because I knocked out half of this one
as a kid. I know it's a pain
in the ass when he knocked.
Got Your teeth for the rest of your life.
You have to replace them.
I felt bad for my parents or my
mother's. I would have freeze. You know,
when your kid knocks out his teeth
and as soon as he hasn't. Yeah. Yeah.
So I've been in a lot of dentist chairs.
I've had a lot of Nova came to my,
in fact when I went to audition for a
man with a plan on the show I'm on now,
and Matt Leblanc had chemistry read with
him. I was at the dentist that morning.
I was at that with you, by the way. Where
are you really? Yeah, I was at the, um,
like when they first were seeing people,
I came in like at the end when they
could, you know, but when they were first,
yeah, when they were first
seeing people, I'm saying,
I remember I parked next to you and I
didn't really know you and I was going to
a reading. Oh, I saw you. I remember
you. Yeah, there was, it was a while ago.
You had a bigger beard at the time, I
think. Yeah, probably a bigger body too.
But I remember because I ran into, I
definitely remember you, cause I mean,
I remember one of the three arts guys
I remember was walking around and I
remember talking to me and he was like,
Kevin,
I like that. Yeah. Like that.
But my mouth was all numb with
Novocain at that, at that thing. Yeah.
Because they had more work they
had to do than they thought.
And I barely got there in time.
I was like zipping over Laurel Canyon,
trying to learn my lines and I go in
and, uh, and I read with, uh, you know,
the side room with Matt Leblanc.
He comes in here,
you want to read the lines a little bit.
So, yeah. And, uh, my mom is all like,
I couldn't, can't move this side. I'm
just trying to do my best, you know. And,
and then he said, lady told me later, you
want go into the producers. And he said,
uh, they said, how was he goes, you know,
he's pretty good as time is good. But,
you know,
I think he might have had a stroke,
but it was like Kinda really numb. But I
do remember seeing you there. I wasn't,
but I remember thinking, man, I hope,
I hope, I hope he has a good audition.
You know, because I, I really,
I feel for anybody who's going in
for an audition because I know how,
how stressful it is. Stressful. I mean,
you must've had a good audition
cause you got the part right.
So I did get the part, now
that I think about it. Yeah.
You worked out. Um, do you
floss? Yeah, we do. Yeah.
What about the uh,
picked you did the waterpik thing.
Don't do the waterpik cause we just got
a bad day toilet seat and that shoots up
some nice streams of water.
But I do floss.
But somebody, my friend,
you know, who, uh,
likes to kind of like give me information
to debunk what I'm doing. He says,
I just read a report where they say
flossing doesn't help bull shoals. Yeah.
Even if it doesn't help, it gets the
food out from between your teeth.
It can get old and smelly. Yeah. Cause I
don't brush. Floss. Yeah. There you go.
Now wait a minute.
How we're big fans of the builtin today's,
how happy are you with it? Well, I
got it from my wife for her birthday,
which is a lot better than the Porta John.
I got her for mother's Day year before.
She did not like that. No, none at all.
She was insulted. But um, loves it. She
loves it. I don't use it that much. What?
Cause I used the office, the
bathroom in my office, but uh,
I did sit on a few times. I love the
heated seat. He didn't see, it's nice,
but it's got a mind of its own.
It's own up and down all night long and
there's water fizzling out and stuff.
And sometimes when I'm
going to the bathroom,
the Siedel go down automatically
and I got to hold it up, you know?
But it's a great, it's a great machine.
It's a lot of it at all different speeds.
I don't know if here's, has the speeds
that we have, we have different speeds.
We have a few.
We have a toto washlet three 50 e and
then this company bio buddy send us one.
Uh, really a washlet here. Yeah. Well
where ours is a black and decker,
so our highest speed is
fracking. Yeah. You can frankly,
hydro, jet cleaning, I mean,
and fire hydrate and nothing says I'm
romance when your wife must be like, wow.
He's really, yeah. So you know, when our
guests come over, we don't tell them.
All of a sudden they got water shooting
up their ass. Yeah. It's nice. Yeah.
I love it. I put it on high
pressure. Yeah. But you know,
nobody comes out in the bathroom,
they're in there for hours or Waterville
has really gone up. Has It? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. But those are a great
invention. They really are.
I recommended for anybody
watch the chocolate away.
Save money on toilet paper.
Yeah, for sure. Um, anything else, Jean?
I don't think so. Um, we had a lot of fun.
We had some good memories from
this show. This was great, man.
I would love for you to come back again
and do it again. Oh, I think we lost.
You know, that'd be great. I would love
it. I would love it. Do you ever travel,
like do the show traveling?
We did years ago now it's just
like closer to my house. Yeah,
we do that. Do you want
to do it? You're half.
But do you ever do it at a comedy club?
If we have and that wasn't satisfying
or it's fun. It's fun. It's just um,
I dunno. I just feels like then
you a card, everything over there,
right?
Yeah.
We've got to bring like computers
and have sound checks and I dunno.
Yeah. I just like to get
your studio. Yeah. Why, why
leave? It's more fun this way.
I like it too. Yeah, I'll definitely come
back. This was fun. Oh good. Thanks. Um,
Kevin Nealon,
you can see him at helium comedy club
in Philadelphia this August and uh,
you can see them on what does
it last man standing? Uh, no,
it's called man with a plan that CBS,
sorry,
I heard right. Tell you, I have such an
appreciation for subcontractors cause I,
I've seen your show a few times and you're
very funny and thank you. I love it.
I think it's such a, it's such a hard
skill, so I've so much admiration for you.
Yeah. It's fun. But yeah,
it's man with a plan on Monday nights
and CBS eight 37 30 central. Yeah.
You're funny. And uh, I have a little
show called hiking with Kevin on Youtube,
hiking with Kevin on Youtube.
Yeah. You invite, uh,
no. So it's, you know, not
a hiker. Anything. It's like
big stars on their town.
They leave me alone. Chelsea handler
was on there. Sarah Silverman.
I don't rule anybody out. Who else is on
there? Who's your Oh, and Wilson. Oh, ah,
love Conan O'brien. Jimmy
Kimmel. Jesus. Yeah. Um,
it's a little nobody guests that he has
on. I had, um, Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
It'll be on this third. Really? Yep.
Um, yeah, a lot of fun people. Bobcat.
Wow. It must be nice to get together with
other white people and just have a nice
conversation. Tiffany Haddish
was on. Yeah. She love her.
Just kind of can Sydney Port da
that you did not have Sydney. Yeah.
And I know you liked with
Tiffany. Yeah, that's fine. Yeah.
You'll check that one out. Yeah.
She's great. Her for a long time.
youtube.com forward slash Kevin Young
comedy or Hashtag hockey with Kevin Hiking
with Kevin. All right. There it is.
Um, we'll leave you on this song.
We have a listeners that
create songs. Um, it's called,
she's got tits by Joseph and John Horez.
Thank you guys.
Thank you Kevin Nealon for being here.
Where is it?
She's got and she knows
how to Hughes try it out.
Try it out right now. She takes, she
knows when to do some,
oh my God,
she's good.
She knows how to,
she takes shit.
Oh
Shit.
Oh Shit.
Okay. And okay. Oh Shit. Okay. And okay.
That's how we do it.
She died. Oh Man. No, no, no.